this next segment is going to be the
totality of my coverage of the Turning
Point USA Women's Summit many of you
sent me clips from this Summit Lauren
bobert and others speaking it was a
totally insane event Turning Point USA
is this on-campus right-wing
organization they did an event over the
weekend which was specifically for uh
young right-wing women I guess I'm just
going to look at one piece of it with
you so we can say we looked at the sort
of stuff that was going on there I'm
going to play a clip for you where a
woman in the audience tells a story
about trans people in the bathroom with
her and then Marjorie Taylor green goes
transphobic and says listen trans people
in bathrooms they're in there to have
sex with you that's why they're there
last year I got my modesty and dignity
taken away from me when I found out that
my school had put multiple biological
males in my locker room and bathrooms
some of which will just sit there and
watch me in the other girls chains okay
that's already not okay if they're they
love to pretend they love to pretend
that this is all about trans people
anybody who just hangs out in a locker
room or a bathroom
checking people out can be reported it
doesn't matter what their gender
identity is either way the behavior
isn't allowed which immediately makes me
skeptical about this story we're just
trying to dress in peace and be able to
go to our PE classes
um me and my dad made quite a fuss last
year at my school and in my community
and I've spoken in front of my very woke
School Board many times however nothing
seems to happen even though they are
violated thousands of girls every day do
you have any advice for me as a 16 year
old trying to change the mind of adults
and make a difference
[Applause]
first of all thank you for your courage
right because yep thank you
because when you when you're speaking
out in your school to your school board
you and your father and your family and
you're standing up against men who are
really a bunch of perverts in your
locker room in your bathroom because
they listen
they want to have sex with you that's
why they're in there that's real they're
it's not they're not saying oh I
identify as a woman and I'm only
attracted to men that is a lie these are
sexual predators they're sexual
predators
there are statistically almost zero
incidents of the kind that they would
have you believe are rampant they're it
just it just doesn't happen
okay
this
my advice for you is your safety is
number one lady
[Music]
number one
and and that when you all join together
and make that known and refuse to accept
these this is also disgusting as I've
said before do you really think that
actual violent predators are going to be
dissuaded by the gender sign on the
bathroom door it's absurd and ridiculous
and of course when then you go further
and say Well there must be hundreds or
thousands or at least dozens of
incidents were based on a falsely stated
gender identity someone hid out in a
bathroom and then assault you find out
that it is essentially non-existent and
it is all part of the story that they
use to prop up this anti-trends
anti-trans paranoia that they are now
obsessed with and that they are raising
money around at the end of the day